the matrix is a series full of
unforgettable action scenes
amazing effects and super hot actors as
a result these movies give us plenty of
excuses to freeze the action for a
closer look and we've collected the most
paused moments from the matrix right
here while she was largely unknown
before the matrix carrie anne moss won
over audiences with her portrayal of
trinity
the enigmatic hacker who guides neo in
his first steps towards discovering the
truth of his cyberpunk world
it's easy to see why too she's one of
the few characters in fiction who's cool
enough to pull off sunglasses at night
and it doesn't hurt that she's
accessorizing with a walking arsenal
she's also one of the first major
characters we meet
she shows up in the opening scene of the
trilogy she's on the run from the police
and it quickly becomes apparent that the
cops aren't the most dangerous things
chasing her
it's during this showdown that trinity
immediately became a fan favorite
thanks to her serious demeanor the high
stakes fight with the authorities
and those incredible martial arts moves
from the very first
moments of the film she helps draw us
into a world that's stranger
and more complicated than we ever
imagined what makes this truly
worth pausing for though are the special
effects it's right here in the opening
that audiences worldwide were introduced
to the
groundbreaking innovative camera
techniques of the wachowski sisters
masterpiece trilogy
the use of multiple cameras to capture a
seamless 360 degree view of the action
changed cinema forever
today the techniques that were showcased
in this movie are used all across the
world of cinema
and taught at film schools everywhere
and this is the moment that
first showed us what was possible it's
one of the greatest action movie
openings
ever and well worth taking some time to
appreciate
there's nothing like some good
old-fashioned body horror to get the
blood pumping and to stun
viewers into hitting the pause button
need proof
okay let's talk about one of the most
messed up moments in sci-fi history
neo played of course by the iconic and
seemingly ageless keanu reeves has
delved into the seedy underworld and the
darkest corners of the dark web looking
for the answer to the question that
keeps him up at night
what is the matrix he's almost ready to
leave his old life
one of boredom isolation wasted
potential and endless corporate
servitude behind
and that's when the ominous and
threatening agent smith comes calling
tracking neo to where he works and
capturing him despite the intervention
of morpheus
and that's when things get interesting
tell me mr anderson what good is a phone
call
if you're unable to speak
based on what we've seen so far we
definitely expect neo to refuse to give
in when the agents attempt to intimidate
him into compliance with whatever
sinister plans they have for him
what we don't expect is our first
glimpse of just how powerful the agents
can be
without even making a single gesture the
mysterious bad guys shut neo up
completely agent smith zips neo's mouth
closed faster than you can say absolute
nightmare
melting his flesh together as neo
powerless
tries and fails to scream on a pure
horror level
it's the scariest thing that happens in
the entire trilogy and
we've got to pause it just to catch our
breath the scene where morpheus offers
neo the choice to learn the truth about
his reality
or go back to his everyday life
symbolized by a red pill
and a blue pill instantly became one of
the most iconic
scenes in movie history it launched a
thousand memes and sent conspiracy
theorists and philosophers alike ablaze
with a million thoughts about what's
really going on in the world
and gave us one of the best visuals in a
movie that's full of iconic shots
neo has finally come face to face with
morpheus the spiritual leader and guide
who will illuminate the true nature of
reality
after his first bizarre brushes with the
agents neo is on a dangerous path to
enlightenment
this is the moment when his departure
from society in the world he is known
will become absolute
but first he has a choice to make
remember
all i'm offering is the truth nothing
more the scene doesn't really have any
suspense to
it after all there wouldn't be much of a
movie left if neo decided to blue pill
his way back to his regular job
although some weird version of office
space that starts with trinity doing
anti-gravity karate does sound like a
pretty fun movie
the way it's presented though is
absolutely thrilling
and incredibly possible the reflection
of neo
and the pills and those awesome mirror
shades hiding fishburn's eyes as his
almost hypnotic voice leads neo to his
choice
is both a beautifully shot bit of
filmmaking and an incredible meditative
image for those times when you're making
your own choices
just remember to have a glass of water
handy the concept of what we call
bullet time has been around filmmaking
for a while before the matrix
and even showed up in a commercial for
smirnoff a few years before
but no one ever pulled it off like the
wachowskis and their technical team
setting up a ring of cameras surrounding
the actors against a green screen
the makers of the matrix were able to
capture breathtaking moments the likes
of which
audiences had never seen though this
film technique appears a few times in
the movie
including in the very first scene the
most iconic moment comes near the end
during neo's rooftop showdown with the
agents
earlier in the film morpheus had hinted
that someday neo
once he accepts his true potential will
be able to move faster than a speeding
bullet
while this may be classic superhero fare
when it's introduced in the movie
it feels revolutionary and breaks into
new territory
and vast power as an agent fires bullets
at our hero
neo pulls a gravity-defying dodge that
looks like he's going for
maximum style points at a limbo
competition
hit pause time and time again to marvel
at the tense moment in the wonderful
filmmaking of this scene
and whatever the idea was called before
it was bullet time forever
after that in the matrix reloaded agent
smith returns
having seemingly gone rogue with a power
that's never been seen in the simulated
world before
much like the way that neo destroyed his
body from the inside out in the first
film
smith is now able to replicate himself
like a virus
taking over other agents and forming an
army dedicated to one purpose
tracking down and eliminating neo and
his friends
thank you my pleasure when smith
eventually tracks neo down
our hero finds himself face to face to
face to face to face with his worst
enemy it seems like the kung fu messiah
has bitten off
way more than he can chew and then the
movie kicks off the
wildest most video game style brawl in
the
entire franchise pausing this scene is
like a fun game of stunt guy
eye spy trying to identify all the
different stuntmen can be pretty
fulfilling
especially when the practical effects
team did such a great job at making it
look like each and every
one of the baddies trying to punch neo
into oblivion is an exact replica of
agent smith
granted there's some bad cgi lurking in
there but spotting that
is a different kind of fun overall this
fight is one of the
ultimate matrix pause moments from neo's
flowing duster to trinity's vinyl tank
top
most of the iconic matrix costumes are
the standard basic black
the one that persephone wears when she
shows up in the matrix reloaded however
is very different it's one of the best
looks in all of cinema history
especially since the person sporting it
is one of the most beautiful women ever
to grace this world
italian actress monica bellucci her
partner the merovingian is a black
market dealer
trafficking in all kinds of things that
regular humans and programs within the
matrix
don't have access to persephone is his
disillusioned wife
she becomes instrumental to leading neo
and his friends to meet the key maker
and
ultimately the resolution of the trilogy
as critical a role as she is in the plot
though
we're not going to lie most of the time
all we remember is that jaw-droppingly
gorgeous latex
cocktail dress on the real world side of
things it was probably pretty sweaty to
wear around under the hot lights of a
film set
in the movie though she just looks
amazing reminding us once again that one
of the greatest superpowers on display
in the matrix trilogy
is the ability to look incredible in
outfits in which the rest of us would
just look ridiculous
while most of the visual effects in the
matrix series still hold up years later
a few of the cgi moments just have not
aged that well
if you need an example just look at the
twins
in the story they're rogue programs
who've essentially malfunctioned and now
just live in the dark underbelly of
computer society
however they can do things and behave in
ways that other programs can't
which in their case means turning
translucent and getting really pointy
teeth let's be real though while the
effect might be a little too reminiscent
of ghostbusters for its own good
still looks pretty cool even if it
doesn't come close to being believable
we are getting aggravated yes we are
they also have a big role in the movie's
best
sequence in a car chase where they're
pitted against morpheus neo and trinity
it's one of the most thrilling
highlights in the entire action-packed
series
and has fans pausing to catch their
breath and take a closer look
a fast-paced big budget scene where
every second is full of tense energy
more than makes up for that weird hair
the scene where neo meets the architect
is easily one of the most
possible moments in the matrix in fact
smashing that
pause button is the only way to see
everything that's going on
if you need a refresher neo has finally
made it to the nerve center of the
matrix itself
and finds himself surrounded by walls
and screens each one reflecting his own
image back at him
that's when he finally meets the
architect the program that seemingly
holds all the answers to the questions
neo has been asking his whole life
neo has questions and so does the
audience but boy oh
boy does the architect have answers
in this notoriously dense scene
straightforward answers are hard to come
by
which is mirrored by the images shown on
the screens behind neil
his whole life and most of the first
movie literally flashes before his eyes
and it's jam-packed with fun matrix
easter eggs for those quick to hit pause
the ultimate confrontation in the matrix
trilogy wasn't the one that many
moviegoers expected
it isn't neo against the heart of the
machines the controlling consciousness
that sought to subjugate and to enslave
humanity for hundreds of years
instead the matrix revolutions ends with
a callback to the same fight that
finished the first film
neo takes on the rogue program created
by the matrix itself
agent smith one last time with the fate
of humanity hanging in the balance
it's peak matrix in just about every way
everything is green
we're in a city that could be anywhere
and nowhere and the atmosphere is heavy
oppressive and ominous jam-packed with
blazing fast action and
very cool special effects any frame of
this scene is worth pausing and
scrutinizing
having already fought legions of smith's
viral duplicates
who have taken over the minds and bodies
of all the inhabitants of the matrix
neo faces the prime agent smith now
inhabiting the body of the oracle
and this battle between two godlike
entities is full of the building
smashing
gravity-defying hard-punching action
that fans of the series
love the breathtaking tension of the
story makes it worth watching but the
incredible effects and stunning fight
choreography
make it worth savoring every single
frame
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one